مقياس السيد الرئيس
كارثة إنسانية في المنطقة الفلسطينية
الصراع الإسرائيلي القسري
الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة يلجأ إليه
لصلاحياتها بموجب المواد بموجب المادة
99 من ميثاق الأمم المتحدة ودعوة المجلس
الأمن يقرر
نهاية
سفك الدماء ومع ذلك، على الرغم من
جهود الغالبية العظمى من الأعضاء
نصائح السلامة كلها مقترحة
تم حظر المشاريع من قبل واشنطن
الذي إلى مكان المساعدة
تزود المدنيين على نطاق واسع
إسرائيل بكل أنواع الأسلحة من
والتي في النهاية
الآن ينبغي أن يكون للجميع
كان ليصبح
دليل على الانزلاق في الجهود الجماعية في
في إطار أنه لا يسببه البعض
مؤسسية موضوعية
المشاكل ولكن بحزم شديد و
الطموحات الأمريكية الأنانية
القيادة لن تكون مبالغة
ليقول أن هناك إجماعا في العالم
الذي يعارضه هذا
معارضة نفسه معارضة نفسه
نفسك للمجتمع الدولي برمته
متحد
تنص على